und jetzt das heute journal
mit gundula gause und claus kleber guten
abend heute hat sich in den flutgebieten
von nrw und rheinland pfalz die lage
stabilisiert das beschreibt die
situation der betroffenen aber nur
ungenügend weil das was ihnen
widerfahren ist was sie verloren haben
welcher berg von arbeit und probleme nun
vor ihnen steht erst langsam deutlicher
wird und weil für viele nicht absehbar
ist wann und ob ihr leben wieder in so
etwas wie normalität zurückfinden kann
frank walter steinmeier hat in solchen
situationen immer wieder ein gefühl
dafür gezeigt was ein staatsoberhaupt in
solcher lage zu tun und zu sagen hat
heute kam er nach erftstadt in das am
schlimmsten betroffene gebiet von nrw
verena garrett martin scheffler
berichten erftstadt blessing wie es nie
aussah aber heute fast jeder in
deutschland kennt das sie hier
tatsächlich sogar noch mit einem blauen
auge davon gekommen sind traut man sich
kaum zu sagen angesichts der natur- und
tausender menschlicher katastrophen aber
noch sieht es so aus als seien hier alle
einwohner mit dem leben davon gekommen
auch alle insassen der fahrzeuge die
nicht mehr heraus waren konnten aus der
unterführung auf der bundesstraße zu
schnell hat er das hochwasser sie
eingeschlossen und ihre autos teilweise
versenkt als der bundespräsident vor der
feuerwehr leitzentrale vor die presse
tritt sieht man ihm und seinen
begleitern die betroffenheit an
spendenkonten sind eingerichtet worden
jeder kann seinen teil dazu beitragen
dass ein wenig von der not der menschen
hier in den betroffenen regionen
gelindert wird vielen menschen hier in
den regionen
ist nichts geblieben außer ihrer
hoffnung
und diese hoffnung dürfen wir nicht
enttäuschen
während das staatsoberhaupt sich zum
ernst der lage äußert geschieht im
hintergrund etwas das seither die
gemüter erregt ministerpräsident armin
laschet und seine gesprächspartner
lachen über was auch immer in der lauten
fahrzeughalle können sie nicht hören was
der bundespräsident gerade sagt aber
natürlich muss ihnen klar sein dass
kameras auf sie gerichtet sind via
twitter entschuldigt sich laschet am
abend dafür dass sei unpassend gewesen
und tue ihnen leid der ministerpräsident
verspricht schnelle hilfe das was wir
erleben ist eine jahrhundertkatastrophe
ganz deutschland wird hier dieser region
helfen alleine werden dass weder die
kommunen noch das land stemmen können
aber wir werden alles tun dass wieder
aufgebaut werden kann was wieder
aufzubauen ist mehr als 23.000
einsatzkräfte helfen allein in nrw wo
und wem sie nur können
feuerwehr polizei bundeswehr
hilfsorganisationen und rettungsdienste
alle im dauereinsatz
die hilfsbereitschaft ist riesengroß
kaum ein nachbar der nicht mit anpackt
und hilft wo er kann
der orts besuch von bundes und landes
präsident und laschet ankündigungen in
sachen schnelle hilfe kommen nicht
überall gut an
ich halte davon gar nichts sie brauchen
nicht zu kommen die sonnenbank besser
mehr da sagen was man machen sollen hier
jetzt haben wir uns somit 200 euro
abgespeist einsetzen wir werden jetzt
glücklich ja da wird versprochen ob es
dann klappt wisse man nicht ich hoffe
aber war somit wenn sie nicht kommen
macht man einen großen vorwurf wenn sie
da sind versuchen sie ihre rolle
natürlich dann auch gut auszufüllen das
auch mitleid zeigen aber natürlich auch
vielleicht paar wählerstimmen fangen das
ist klar meine sorge meine angst die ich
gleich wieder in euskirchen zu hause
habe die kann mir dann auch und
steinmeier nicht
es hat aufgehört zu regnen wenigstens
das und auch die große persönliche
hilfsbereitschaft macht den opfern des
hochwassers hoffnung
anna maria schuck liefert uns den
überblick über die wichtigsten orte der
katastrophe am dritten tag danach und
beginnt auch in nordrhein westfalen
hier kam es nicht ganz so schlimm wie
erwartet in wassenberg pro prüfen an der
niederländischen grenze brach in der
nacht ein damm der ruhe
besonders bitter noch im letzten jahr
hat man der gemeinde vorgerechnet dass
sie keine dampfer stärkung braucht jetzt
musste der gesamten stadtteil evakuiert
werden
etwa 700 menschen wurden in sicherheit
gebracht
dann die relative erleichterung der
ortsteil ist zwar überflutet aber nicht
so stark wie befürchtet die pegelstände
stagnieren wir sind trocken geblieben
zum glück hier also da sind wir echt
sehr sehr froh dafür und dankbar dass es
bis dahin hat wasser nicht durch
gelaufen ist aber trotzdem ist es echt
eine katastrophe
viel dramatischer ist die situation im
großraum ahrweiler in rheinland pfalz
allein hier sind nach aktuellem stand 98
menschen ums leben gekommen
mindestens 670 wurden verletzt viele
haben auch personenschäden zu beklagen
wo dann vielleicht angehörige fehlen
für uns ist jetzt glücklicherweise nur
sachschaden aber auch die müssen
beseitigt werden
von daher jede hand die hilfsbereite im
inneren erinnerung die finger war schon
ab dem ersten tag an sobald das stark
ereignis hier
angekündigt war wieder ganz entsprechend
warnen so viele hilfsbereite leute da in
dernau an der ahr kämpfen sie gegen den
schlamm der mit den wassermassen kam
schlamm der abgetragen werden muss bevor
er verhärtet ausgerechnet wasser würde
dabei helfen aber wieder leitungswasser
noch strom geschweige denn netz haben
sie hier die komplette infrastruktur
zusammengebrochen
ich glaube nicht dass hier nach oben
geschleppt werden
für alle ab so dass also dass das wieder
aufzubauen
wir haben damit ab
wir sind erst mal probieren
dernau drei tage nach der katastrophe
das aufräumen im aartal hat gerade erst
begonnen
man kann so eine geschichte nicht in
zahlen schreiben obwohl zahlen schon zum
lagebild gehört dass mittlerweile über
140 tote gezählt worden dass die
endgültige zahl noch höher sein wird so
viele tote durch regenfälle in einem
reichen land mit hatte man gedacht
zuverlässiger infrastruktur und
zivilschutz das wird noch gegenstand von
scharfen fragen sein müssen
auch weil dieses lagebilder ein mosaik
aus tausenden einzelschicksalen ist jede
und jeder mit seinen eigenen erfahrungen
unsere reporterin alissa jung ist mit
einer familie mit der sie in diesen
tagen schon zusammen war heute nach
hause zurückgekehrt in das was ihr
zuhause war
drei tage nach der katastrophe in schuld
dürfen die chef was ihr haus wieder
betreten
es ist einsturzgefährdet die feuerwehr
prüft was abgerissen werden muss mutter
sonja und tochter hannah können endlich
nachsehen was noch zu retten ist auf dem
fußboden schlamm in jeder ritze
das war einmal hannas schlafzimmer der
blick aus dem ersten stock apokalyptisch
neben abend als es passiert ist kann
meine besten freunde noch und hat mir
bewusst ist geschenkt gebracht die
familie versucht seit tagen den mut
nicht zu verlieren
doch natürlich sind auch ihre kräfte
fast aufgebraucht
ruhiger wurde merken wenn man nicht das
gefühl plötzlich irgendwie ganz
komisches gefühl
die schäfers hoffen so sehr dass das
glück bald wieder in ihr haus
zurückkehrt direkt gegenüber lebt die 14
jährige anna ihre beine sind voller
blutergüsse und blaue flecken ganze 40
hat sie gezählt das wasser war so viel
stärker als sie ich habe am anfang
versucht die haushalte zu machen das hat
gar nichts gebracht
mir stand das wasser hüfthoch ich habe
nicht gesehen wo ich lange wasser
schwimmen der boden hat sich auch gelöst
ich bin gefallen sachen gegen mich
gestorben
es ging einfach alles zu schnell sich
daran erinnern macht gänsehaut
gestern wäre annas letzter schultag vor
den ferien gewesen
das ist alles was zählt hört man hier an
jeder ecke froh am leben zu sein
nachdem das wasser sich durch den halben
ort gefressen hat behelfsmäßig gibt es
hier nun wieder eine straße drumherum
wird gebaggert
alle packen mit an sich ablenken nicht
nachdenken müssen was ihnen hier
geschehen ist für anna jetzt noch viel
klarer als zuvor
sie will später mal zur feuerwehr wenn
noch mal hochwasser ist oder was anderes
passiert möchte ich mit im einsatz sein
ihre sommerferien wird anna wohl hier
verbringen um ihr zuhause wieder
aufzubauen
viel glück das aktionsbündnis
katastrophenhilfe hat ein spendenkonto
eingerichtet stichwort zdf hochwasser
deutschland die iban lautet de 65 104
106 100 104 106 100 weitere
informationen unter spenden zdf de und
im zdf textseite 890 der überflutete
westen blieb heute von weiterem regen
verschont aber hinter sich hat
deutschland dieses wettersystem noch
nicht am abend haben extreme regenfälle
auch im südosten von sachsen zu
überflutungen geführt zum teil viele
mehr als 100 liter pro quadratmeter im
sächsischen neustadt ist der kleine bach
polens binnen kurzem auf fast den
zehnfachen stand geschrieben
innerhalb weniger minuten sollen im
zentrum der kleinstadt keller voll
gelaufen seien mehrere orte im
osterzgebirge sind betroffen zahlreiche
straßen im landkreis sächsische schweiz
wegen überflutung gesperrt
auch in österreich kommt es zur stunde
nach schweren regenfällen zu
überflutungen
teile der innenstadt von hallein im
salzburger land stehen unter wasser dort
habe sich ebenfalls ein bach zu einem
reißenden fluss verwandelt wie die
polizei berichtet die situation sei sehr
angespannt und teils dramatisch und im
osten belgiens haben die heftigen
überschwemmungen der letzten tage
ebenfalls massive zerstörungen
angerichtet
die zahl der todesopfer in der stark
betroffenen provinz lüttich ist auf 27
gestiegen das hochwasser der maas hat
insgesamt etwa 120 belgischen gemeinden
verwüstungen angerichtet das schicksal
von etwa 100 menschen ist ungewiss
regierungschef deko rief für dienstag
einen nationalen tag der trauer aus
corona angesichts zunehmender
infektionen und teils stagnierender
impfzahlen warnen experten vor einer
vierten corona welle im herbst das
robert koch institut meldet 1608
neuinfektionen binnen eines tages das
sind 656 mehr als vergangenen samstag
außerdem kamen 22 todesfälle hinzu die
sieben tage incidents ist weiter
gestiegen auf jetzt 9 4 in frankreich
haben tausende gegen die neuen
verschärften corona maßnahmen der
regierung protestiert vor allem gegen
die impfpflicht für medizinisches
personal ungeimpften soll außerdem der
zugang etwa zu restaurants oder bars
erschwert werden auch in frankreich
steigen die neuinfektionen wieder
deutlich knapp eine woche vor eröffnung
der olympischen spiele in tokio gibt es
im athletendorf einen ersten corona fall
ein funktionär aus dem ausland sei bei
ankunft am flughafen negativ im
athletendorf dann positiv getestet
worden und jetzt in quarantäne berichtet
das organisationskomitee wegen der
steigenden infektionszahlen gilt in
tokio kroner notstand auch während der
olympischen spiele vom 23 juli bis zum 8
august die goldene palme der
filmfestspiele von cannes geht an einen
feministischen horrorfilm das scheint
eine film gattung zu sein die mir bisher
nicht bekannt war
der begriff wird jetzt jedenfalls
überall als beschreibung eingesetzt und
da den großen preis gewonnen hat darf
man davon ausgehen dass es kein
schrecklicher film ist feministischer
horrorfilm scheint zu bedeuten dass der
horror von frauen an männern ausgeübt
wird allerdings solchen männern die es
verdient haben
shiva und preis ist nun sie ahnen es in
den händen einer frau sabine schulz hat
die details kann ist zurück mit einer
wucht als wolle man das verlorene letzte
jahr gleich mehrfach wettmachen
umso größer die spannung im bett
empfehlen das team von jurypräsident
spike lee die zukunft des kinos
vertreten sieht die goldene palme geht
an die regisseurin julia du corbeau für
ihren film titan und das ist eine
sensation denn die französin ist erst
die zweite goldene palmen gewinnerin in
der gesamten geschichte des festivals
film geht es um alex jahr die frau die
eine titanplatte im schädel trägt seit
einem unfall in der kindheit autos liebt
sie seither mehr als menschen und wer
ihr zu nahe kommt muss sterben
ein film so grausam wie
bedeutungsschwanger rollenbilder werden
in frage gestellt weibliche männliche
quer identitäten
[Musik]
mensch und maschine
farrow und liebes ersatz
eine jury alle tour de force mit
unglaublicher power und energie so
aufwühlend wie provokant ein film der in
cannes schwer polarisiert hat und doch
die goldene palme verdient denn die tan
ist ein radikales ein visionäres werk
das alle gängigen konventionen sprengt
ein neuer weiblicher blick auf unsere
aus den fugen geratene welt
feministische horror aspekte und wut mit
ihren bildern so faszinierend wie gesagt
es ist erst der zweite spielfilm dieser
regisseurin eine entdeckung
es war ein ungewöhnlich starker jahrgang
kann ein ausnahme festival in einem
ausnahmejahr und hier fehlen noch die
wetteraussichten und die gewinnzahlen
vom lotto die lauten ohne gewähr
17 25 30 33 38 49 superzahl 9 mehr auf
lotto zdf de und im zdf text das wetter
beruhigt sich nur am alpenrand regnet es
noch recht stark mit unwetter ist aber
erstmal nicht zu rechnen morgen am
sonntag ist es wechselnd bewölkt mit
viel sonne im südwesten und wenigen
schauern an der nordsee
der regen in südbayern lässt nach
gewitter gibt es kaum noch die
temperatur erreicht 21 bis 28 grad
auch in der neuen woche bleibt es ruhig
und vor allem im süden länger sonnig
schauer sind selten bei 18 bis 27 grad
und alles vom sport jetzt gleich im
sportstudio mit katrin müller-hohenstein
möchte es hat jeder gemerkt wie feige
ich mich davor gedrückt hat nach diesem
film gleich wieder in die kamera zu
gucken jetzt auch im grunde laden in
schönen abend
[Musik]